[Raphtalia: Naofumi-sama!]
Hey. So what are you ... what are
you watching?
Oh, I'm just watching Shield Hero.
Oh no, I know this. This is the new isekai , isn't it?
Yeah, I'm actually really enjoying it to be fair.
Yeah, I know right. Like I know it's isekai, but I just, I just can't stop watching man.
I mean it's just good isekai trash really
Yeah, yeah. I know, like I mean I'm isekai trash as well. So I know exactly what you mean.
Yeah, I don't really see what's so great about Raphtalia
but did you hear that Kevin Penkins did the music for it? It's pretty high.
Yeah I mean ...
Wha .. wait. What did you just say?
Oh Kevin Penkin.He's the guy who put the music for..
No, no, no, no, no, b-before that.
Oh, Raphtalia?
Yeah, I don't see what's so great about her. I think Filo is way better
It's just kind of refreshing to see a main character that doesn't have to kill everything
[muffled arguments over confusion]
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Um
Uh yeah, I'm I'm sorry what?
You'd take some five day old chocobo over the loving embrace of the purest raccoon girl this year?
What are you some sick pervert?
Isn't Raphtalia like 12?
In raccon years she'd be a grown woman, right?
Tsk. You know what?
I don't have to defend myself to you. She's a ball of sunshine and love and you don't deserve her anyway
Garnt, what the fuck is wrong with you?
I'm in extreme distress at how shit your opinion is.
I mean, honestly, I really just don't understand the appeal of her
She's kind of like every other good bit of waifu
Garnt, what are you doing?
I'm trying to find a glove to slap you in the face with it.
Chill out, it's just anime waifus, man.
It's WAR, Connor.
One that you could have realized that you are on the wrong side of history.
Are we really making a big deal out of this?
You're like a brother to me.
I thought we had this unshakeable bond that couldn't be broken by anything.
I would have died for you.
What the fuck are you on about man?
Who else Connor? Who else have you backstabbed me with using your awful taste?
It's kind.. it's kind of funny actually, I was meaning to tell you that Rikka's thighs aren't that thicc.
Are.. are you disrespecting me in my own house?
I mean you know this is my house.
Okay.
For the last time it was the bareness of her thighs combined with her thigh to waist ratio
that caused everyone to call it thicc
Do you not know what I mean?
So it just boils down to who has the better hentai of them?
Hentai?
How long until you searched hentai of her?
Is this what you think this is about? I genuinely love her design.
And she just seems like a chill person. I would actually hang out with in real life.
Best girl is so much more than just hentai.
So how long until you searched for hentai?
Almost immediately
Yeah, that's what I thought.
Who else? Who was best girl in Bunny Girl Senpai?
Kaede.
Wrong. It was Mai. Darling in the FranXX?
Ichigo.
Do you just want to see the world burn?!
I mean you know what, what's wrong with her?
She caused a big enough shitstorm (that) the United Nations treated it as an international incident.
I mean I just thought she was the best girl on the show.
Oh my god. I thought being objectively wrong was just an urban legend.
I just think that Zero Two was a bit overrated and everyone was obsessed with...
Garnt what... what are you doing?
Hi there. Can you connect me to the police? I'd like to report a hate crime.
Garnt, you can't call 999 for that. That's not a crime
Oh, yeah? Just fucking watch me.
Why don't you tell them about all the lolis you've watched in anime then?
You and I both knows that as long as she's a 200-year old loli
there is absolutely no moral obligation to feel weird about anything at all.
Yeah, yeah, you're right.
And that's just the law right?
Yeah! I mean, you know also she's a demon lord, that holds up in a court of law.
Thank you. Something we finally agree on.
Look this is... this is stupid. We're sitting here arguing about the fictional aspects of girls that don't exist
I mean, come on we are friends. How long we known each other? We can respect each other's tastes.
Yeah, yeah. You are right.
Sorry, I just .. I just get heated sometimes
Truce?
Truce.
Raccoon girls are fucking stupid anyways.
I fucking knew it you little piece of shit!
*cue cheerful music to break up tension*
[yeah, except if you think Bitch Malty (Shield Hero) is Waifu Material]
[goddamnit, Gigguk...
no u]